there is no way that earth is the only
place out of the entire universe to
contain life and mark my words in our
lifetimes we will confirm that not only
does life live outside of planet Earth
but we can find it right here in our
very own solar system and if you think
that sounds unlikely just wait until you
hear the details that I'm about to share
with you in this video but let me start
off by sharing some of the unbelievable
places that we've recently discovered
contains life to the utter surprise and
amazement of scientists take for example
radiation eating bacteria that they've
discovered living inside of nuclear
reactors to the complete shock of
scientists that not only did the
radiation not kill the bacteria but the
bacteria was thriving off of eating
nuclear waste something they never
thought possible another great example
is the abundance of life that they've
discovered living inside and on top of
hydrothermal vents deep underneath the
ocean superheated toxic environments
once thought to be completely
inhospitable to life we've since learned
that many species make it their home
whether it be various types of tubeworms
limpets scale worms different types of
bacteria snails sea spiders even
different types of fish and octopus make
this in hospital environment their home
another interesting example is when they
found living microbes living more than a
half-mile underneath the Antarctic Ice
Sheet
after being without Sun or air for
millions of years and these little
organisms were thriving but a far more
amazing example is when they found
living bacteria on the outside of the
International Space Station and of
course this created a lot of debate on
whether the bacteria came from humans
back here on earth and the bacteria
survive the one sagat's of space or
whether the bacteria had came from outer
space entirely and it seems to be
determined that it came from humans but
the interesting part is the fact that
for more than three years this bacteria
had survived the vacuum of space I mean
something that could survive a 500
degree fahrenheit temperature swing
between the difference of sunlight and
shade so of course they decided to do
further experiments and they decided to
send up what are known as tardigrades
which are eight legged and vertebrates
microscopic weather consider to be the
indestructible life-form which will be
the last
on earth when the earth eventually dies
and the Sun goes out because these are
known to live in extreme environments
withstanding radiation in fact they can
go without food or water for more than
30 years and can also survive like I
said several hundred degree temperature
swings and they also - lived outside in
the vacuum of space without an issue I
mean how incredible is that the point of
these examples is to show us that places
that we didn't think that life could
survive actually can and this is just
the beginning of what we thought we knew
and this reminds me of a quote from
Jurassic Park I'm sure you remember it
life finds away so this brings me to the
emphasis of this video which is the fact
that there are five moons inside of our
solar system they have an incredible
likelihood for having some sort of life
on it and these five moons are found
orbiting around Jupiter and Saturn so
let me start off with the moons around
Jupiter and go with Europa which has
been documented of having these massive
water plumes going out of it out of this
icy planet so it confirms that there's
some sort of geothermal activity just
like we have on earth there is a heat
source inside of this moon and there is
a liquid ocean with get this more than
twice the volume of all Earth's oceans
combined so this of course reminds me of
the examples that I just used with
hydrothermal vents as well as Antarctica
microbes that who knows what could be
living underneath the ice sheets I mean
if there's heap there the question
becomes well how warm are these oceans
and what could be living inside of them
now the two other moons of Jupiter that
could potentially have life is Ganymede
and Callisto which are believed to have
under surface oceans underneath the rock
potentially more than 60 miles or 100
kilometres deep underneath the surface
is where these bodies of water are
believed to be and this of course
reminds me of a discovery how they found
a massive ocean inside of the Earth's
mantle more than a third of the way to
the core itself and real quick take a
look here press pause so you can see
this real quick these are the five moons
that I'm discussing here and you see the
size comparison but Ganymede is the
largest moon in the entire solar system
and in fact it's the ninth largest
object in the entire solar system
including the Sun but when you look at
pictures of it you can't help but think
that like WoW is there something living
there
on the surface but what we do know about
it is that it has a salty ocean with
more water than planet Earth just think
about that but where it gets even
crazier is that scientists think that
this ocean is 60 miles or 100 kilometers
thick more than ten times the depth of
the Earth's oceans but the very fact
that it's a saltwater ocean makes you
wonder what could possibly be living
there
I mean 71% of the earth's surface is
covered in our saltwater ocean and we've
explored less than 5% of that so we
cannot presume to know what's going on
in the ocean underneath the surface of
some moon a billion miles away now let
me transition to the moons of Saturn and
start off by talking about Titan Titan
also has an atmosphere and from the
pictures itself it does look hospitable
but you need to know that it's very cold
in fact negative 292 degrees Fahrenheit
which is negative 180 degrees Celsius
but that temperature is not far off from
the survivability of bacteria on the
outside of the International Space
Station at negative 238 degrees
Fahrenheit so it makes you wonder also
take a look at these surface photos as
they had a lander go on it and these are
basically the only photos of it that
exists very few they're not very good as
you can tell but what's so interesting
is that there are methane lakes
confirmed to be on the surface of Titan
and methane on planet Earth only comes
from living organisms which is the
reason why so many scientists speculate
the possibility of life on Titan but
this makes me wonder what the
possibilities are I mean we all remember
the Gulf oil spill from several years
ago and then how they discovered that
this bacteria was eating in thriving off
the oil spill and basically cleaned most
of it up all by itself and it completely
shocked scientists so who knows we could
possibly be going on on the moon Titan
now the last moon I'm discussing is
Enceladus which is has a liquid ocean
frozen beneath the surface and also has
the geysers and water plumes in fact
more than 100 geysers have been
documented so it confirms that there's
some sort of geothermal activity on this
moon so the question again becomes how
warm is the ocean underneath and from
various data that you've obtained this
moon has nearly all of the ingredients
to support life and the only way to
confirm the rest of it is to go down and
land on this moon
and discover what's there so again when
we remind ourselves of how tardigrades
can survive in radiation the vacuum of
space and several hundred degree
temperature swings or the various
different forms of life that are living
in hydrothermal vents or a bacteria
living in nuclear reactors and
underneath the Antarctica ice sheets we
really have to remind ourselves that we
just don't know everything about life
and going back to that Jurassic Park
quote life finds away and this reminds
me of a study conducted by NASA when
they determined that Venus was very
likely to have been habitable for two
billion years at one point in the
distant past so there are at least five
chances that there is life living on
moons in our solar system not just one
or two possibilities but five think
about the incredible odds of that and
the fact that there's geothermal vents
there there's obviously a few
ingredients that are absolutely
necessary for life hydrogen carbon but
we already know that some of these
things already exists on the moon and we
already know in these incredible
miraculous places where like his lit
live in outer space and here on earth we
have to start asking new questions and
although I'm not saying that there's
some conspiracy to keep this knowledge
from the masses because there's not but
most mainstream news networks don't even
report on these stories you have to go
to science websites to actually learn
about them and seek it out yourself
which makes me wonder how much of this
these specifics about these moons are
being taught to kids in school today
can anyone leave a comment and answer
that question because it's very
important that the new generation of
open-minded people are knowing that
there's a possibility that in their
lifetime we are going to discover alien
life in our very own solar system which
will be a shock to many people so for us
to progress faster than we have been by
this establishment that has kept us from
going back to the moon I mean we haven't
even been to Mars yet I remember
distinctly being in the seventh grade
and there was articles in the newspaper
I remember our teachers sharing it with
us how NASA said that yeah we'll
probably be in Mars landing on Mars with
people by 2016 and that was back in 1996
1997 here we are
2018 and we were years away from going
there right so that's why it's so
important that more people become aware
of this information because that's what
it's going to take is a new generation
of people that are wanting to make
change and look into things themselves
that are not willing to accept the
status quo of what we've been enduring
for the last several decades having not
been back to the moon in set forty
freakin years right but I'll wrap it up
there I have many other videos to come
and a bunch of different topics I have
some really good videos planned and the
near-term future so I'll leave it at
that
I'm Jimmy this is right in sight like
and subscribe and leave me a comment let
me know what your thoughts are on this
topic but I'll leave it at that
by now